Describe "Cha Cha Real Smooth" in three words.
Describe "Cha Cha" in three words.
Okay.
It's so good.
I can't believe college is over.
You have a job now, or...
We're not allowed to talk about jobs
at the Bat Mitzvah party.
So, you either don't have a job,
or you have a bad job.
I have a bad job, yeah.
Ooh, okay.
What is the secret to becoming
an exceptional party starter?
A savior complex.
No.
The key is to come outside of yourself,
but that's also the danger too.
How much does a party starter
get paid, I wonder.
I think they said just under
what an unhappy pharmaceutical exec makes.
What the hell does that mean?
Do you believe in soulmates?
-I believe in soulmates, yes.
-Yeah, me too.
I think on the earth,
we all have like a ton of soulmates.
You annoy me more than anybody
in the whole world.
-Right, but you also love me more than--
-But I love you so much.
More than anyone in the world.
Mmm... I love you so much.
I'll bet you three hundred dollars
that I can get Lola on a dance floor.
I will give you a thousand dollars.
Margaret told me that she wants to kiss.
Uh-oh.
Do you remember your first kiss?
My first kiss was...
(makes kissing sound)
I was at night in a skate park
and, like, I wasn't supposed to be there.
And it was, like, cool.
-Naturally.
-I'm not lying.
What was it like having Leslie Mann
as your mom?
I really thought of her as my mom,
so after each scene
I was expecting her to be like,
"Good job!"
It's so cute. It's so good.
But I would forget that I'm--
-The director?
-The director.
You have a job to do right now.
Why did you pick "Cha Cha Real Smooth"
as the title of the film?
It's the part in the dance
where you do your own dance.
That's the best answer
you've given of
any question I've ever heard
you've been asked.
Thank you so much.
Have you ever been to Funkytown?
If not,
would you like to go to Funkytown?
Of course.
I think we killed it.